the browns and the steelers get together
this weekend this is a rivalry that
never seems like much of a rivalry
because usually the steelers are good
and usually the browns aren't well this
year
the browns are the best team the
steelers have seen so far this season
because the steelers
they they beat the giants and that game
at one point could have gone either way
they beat the broncos that game could
have gone either way they beat the
texans
that game could have gone either way and
the eagles could have gone either way
now come the browns who lost week one to
the ravens won four in a row
and one of the the fact that they're
both good right now
causes us to possibly overlook the miles
garrett mason rudolph thing the fact
that rudolph isn't playing
also causes us to overlook it but miles
garrett public enemy number one in
pittsburgh there will be fans in the
building only 5 500
mike tomlin addressing the reunion
between the pittsburgh steelers and
miles garrett here's tomlin
there's a lot on the table in reference
to this game in terms of stakes
there are four and one team we're trying
to remain undefeated
um you know we're not looking for that
low hanging fruit or that
a reality tv story lines and so forth uh
this is a big game here in 2020
yeah you know the problem is reality tv
sells and sometimes the low-hanging
fruit tastes the best because it's the
ripest
um but uh look it would be different
if it was a full stadium it would be far
different
for miles garrett and it would be
different if the guy that he whacked
over the head with his own helmet was
actually playing in the game
so and miles garrett's come a long way
since then and it really does feel like
water well under the bridge and out to
sea after everything we've dealt with
since that night last year that feels
like 10 years ago
frankly but you know it's part of the
reality it's part of the rivalry and
we can call it a rivalry now that both
teams
are vying for the opportunity to to
challenge the ravens for the top of the
nfc north shoreen
or afc north you know i you know i go
along
back a long way with miles garrett and
think an awful lot of him he grew up
here in arlington went to high school
here and
then obviously played for my alma mater
at texas a m and i know what a good kid
he is at heart
and he is still a kid despite his size
and i'm glad that he's come a long way
uh in the past few months because i
thought it was going to be a scarlet
letter for him and we
talked a lot about other teams and other
players are going to try to incite him
now that they know what he's capable of
and he and he hasn't done any of that he
hasn't reacted because you know other
players are saying things to him and
they're trying to get him to get a
15-yard penalty and he hasn't done
anything
and he's been awesome on the field and
i'm really happy for how far he's come
but he's second in the league with
with six sacks behind aaron donald and
has three force fumbles which
which leads the league he's become very
good at that strip sack
and just been an outstanding player and
a model citizen this year so i'm
thrilled with where he is and i hope
that this week goes as well as the rest
of the season has for him
because you you know this is not a game
probably that he's looking forward to
and
you know he said some things about ben
roethlisberger when he first came into
the
into the draft as the number one overall
pick he said he couldn't wait to
sac ben roethlisberger so they're
they're going to be gunning for him
they're going to say stuff they're going
to try to get that 15-yard penalty he's
got to
keep keep us cool one more time
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports